was it Mario Cuomo who was the one who
said You campaign yes in poetry but you
govern in prose I thought out this week
I saw what I thought was the funniest
story I've seen in a long time about the
Taliban being upset about having to
govern now and it's true you know it's
it's a lot of fun to be the
Revolutionary you know it's a lot of
jihad is fun it just is but then you win
they won and now they have to like
govern this country so Vice news which I
used to be a part of uh they did this
whole story on they interviewed a lot of
these Taliban commanders who are now
living in the capital cabal and they
don't like it uh one of them said I
missed the Jihad life
for all the good things it had I love
this husafa a former sniper
said life was simple and free during
Jihad the Taliban used to be free of
restrictions but now we sit in one place
behind a desk don't you hate that
uh man sue great guy
um complained about that he's hacked up
to here with the traffic I am not making
this up he said last year it was
tolerable but now it's become more
congested
we had a great degree of Freedom these
days you have to go to the office before
8 A.M and stay there until four
[Laughter]
uh Camron said we are tested by cars
positions wealth and women
have fallen into these seemingly sweet
but actually bitter traps oh yeah Connie
from accounting she's uh showing a
little ankle around the office
anyway
the I thought the complaints of the time
so we looked into it a little further
there are some other complaints that
Taliban have about working at the office
would you like to hear some of them
I thought you might
um for example uh I keep getting my
beard Stuck In The copier isn't as a
I can't find wing tips go go with my
Suicide vest
uh the snack machine is always out of
opium
I'm getting carpal tunnel in my
beheading hand yeah that's
[Laughter]
I tell co-workers I used to blow up
statues of Buddha and they say Okay
Boomer
I'm used to working from cave
[Laughter]
I was due for a promotion and who do
they give it to the warlord's son
no women are allowed to work here but HR
still makes us sit through a sexual
harassment seminar
and of course you try running accounts
payable without Jews